me preguntan cuál es la factorización de
primos de 95 así que vamos a sacar aquí
el pizarrón para ver cuál es la
factorización de primos del 95
voy a poner aquí a 95 con mi pluma 95 y
vamos a actualizarlo en primos
bueno para factorizar los primos primero
vamos a pensar en los primos más chicos
a 95 tiene mitad no no tiene mitad lo
primero que se me ocurre es que 95 tiene
quinta de hecho no tiene tercera porque
la suma de sus dígitos no es divisible
entre 3 por lo tanto tiene quinta la
quinta del 95 cuánto es bueno pues 95 en
35 esto va a ser vamos a hacerlo aquí 95
entre 5 es una vez 1 por 55 sobran 4 y
después bajo el 5 y aquí es 99 por 55 y
tengo de residuos 0 por lo tanto nuestro
gran 19 y 19 es un número primo tú te
puedes acordar porque es los primeros
números primos que existen
3 5 7 11 13 17 y 19 y si no puedes
verificar que 19 no tiene ni tercera ni
mitad ni quinta y séptima ni nada de
nada por lo tanto mi respuesta va a ser
5 por 19 la factorización en primos de
95 es cinco por 19 así que vamos a
ponerla por aquí la respuesta sería a 5
por x
9 x 19 y entonces comprobando respuesta
y estamos bien vamos a la siguiente
pregunta cuál es la factorización en
primos de 85 así que regresemos aquí a
nuestro pizarrón y vamos a trabajar
ahora con el 85 85 a 85 cuánto suman sus
dígitos 85 es 13 por lo tanto creo que
tampoco es divisible entre 3 85 tiene
quinta porque acaba en 5 entonces 85 lo
voy a dividir entre 5 es 1 sobran 3 bajo
el 5 y aquí obtengo un 7 7 % 35 y me
sobran 0 y qué creés si yo les hago
quinta 85 obtengo 17 que justo habíamos
dicho hace rato que también es un número
primo por lo tanto ya tengo la respuesta
185 los factores son primos es lo mismo
que 5 por 17 y vamos a poner la
respuesta para ver que estamos bien
la respuesta estaría 5 x
17 y comprobamos respuesta perfecto
estamos muy bien así que vamos con la
siguiente cuál es la factorización en
primos de 5 pues eso está muy fácil 5 no
tiene mitad no tiene tercera 5 tiene
quinta entonces la factorización de
primos de 5 es 5 ahora ten cuidado si tú
escribes 5 por 1 te estarías equivocando
porque recuerda que el 1 no es un número
primo recuerda que un número primo es
aquel que es divisible entre sí mismo y
la unidad pero el 1 hace trampa él es la
unidad por lo tanto la respuesta sería
solamente 5 la factorización en primos
de cinco en cinco y comprobando
respuesta ya está tenemos tres
respuestas correctas
así que por aquí voy a dejar este vídeo
y nos vemos en el siguiente